E aí
G1
É verdade é Com muito gosto aqui hoje e
tinha preparado esta conversa convosco
sobre a desinformação tentando explicar
vos que saber pois distinguir o que é
verdade do que é mentira é a que um dos
grandes problemas do nosso tempo EA data
não podia ter sido mais adequada porque
estamos hoje perante a evidência de que
160 milhões de eleitores naquela que é
uma das democracias mais antigas e mais
bem estruturadas do mundo se dividem
sobre coisas que são preocupantemente
pouco factuais não são assuntos
políticos dividem sobre saber se há ou
não uma intervenção humana no
aquecimento global preocupa o soro saber
se usar máscara é ou não uma forma
eficaz de evitar a propagação do 19 e e
este tipo de problema que nós vimos
agora nas eleições Americanas há cerca
de uma hora chegamos até a não perceber
como é que não se conseguem distinguir o
que são os votos legais do que são os
votos e legais
e esse problema de desinformação afeta
as nossas democracias como nós podemos
ver por exemplo dos Estados Unidos mas
afeta também a nossa vida cotidiana e
até de uma forma muito mais privada a
forma como Nós pensamos e a por isso o
que eu gostaria de vos dizer aqui é que
este é um problema do nosso tempo e
trouxe esta imagem das materiais que
vieram comigo e uma reportagem fiz um
para isso nem sequer existe e é
transnístria são estas bonequinhas
russas cabem todas umas dentro das
outras eu te explicar que muitas vezes
quando analisamos o problema da
desinformação muita gente os valoriza e
desvaloriza o porquê com pensa de uma
maneira que quanto a mim é insuficiente
errada que isto é apenas um problema de
geopolítica que foi inventado pela
propaganda russa muitas vezes ouvimos o
exemplo do caso Cambridge analytica mas
o caso Cambridge analytica teve um
desenvolvimento até hoje a também e por
isso As Bonequinhas russas há quem pense
que dentro desse problema da geopolítica
pó
e o outro problema que é o peso muito
grande do das grandes plataformas do
Google e do Facebook que são suas vendas
do YouTube e do WhatsApp e do Instagram
e que os seus grandes conhecimentos de
Inteligência Artificial permitem que
fazer com que os algoritmos sejam a não
só secretos mas dominadores nesse
problema uma terceira destas explicações
que considera insuficientes e que por
outro lado os estados não são capazes de
regular as grandes plataformas e não tem
nenhuma capacidade de dominar o que é a
propagação de desinformação pela grande
empresas mas o que queremos uma maneira
um pouco mais simples e talvez um pouco
mais eficiente de olhar para o problema
sem tentar criar um ministério da
Verdade seja no estado qualquer ou seja
numa nestas grandes empresas nestas
grandes plataformas e penso que é também
mais fácil para nós podemos encarar como
um problema nosso do que voltamos a
responsabilidade
e limpou aparecer o ícone falei ou para
qualquer outro desses lugares distantes
eu passei os meus últimos dois anos a
ler quase diariamente fake uso que eu
imagino que vocês pensam que não é nada
demente empregável mas eu parti para
este trabalho sem sequer pensar que
havia feito em os criados em Portugal e
havia havia um negócio
e por exemplo este site que vos
apresento aqui eram site feito no Canadá
que visava apenas cliques publicitários
que é que não haveria nenhuma outra
razão atrás da criação deste site fake
News que não é de fazer com que muita
gente clicasse no site e com isso o site
tinha dinheiro e era bastante dinheiro
pelas minhas contas muito conservador há
cerca de dez mil réis por mês a fazer
fake News sobre personalidades políticas
como exemplo temos aqui mas Encontrei
muito Muitas outras camadas do problema
não Só a do negócio e da convicção
também a forma como o ódio se propaga a
forma como as fake News foram
instrumentais para o crescimento do
populismo na Europa em vários países
europeus como na Itália na França na
Alemanha na Áustria a vídeos que eram
produzidos na Holanda a partir de sites
anónimos e que faziam propaganda a ter
refugiados propaganda racista é tudo
isso ajuda-nos a perceber exatamente
onde é que vivemos e convivemos quando
vamos nos transportes públicos e ouvimos
uma das pessoas o medo que as pessoas se
referem nas suas conversas percebemos a
esta estranha imagem da polarização da
forma como os Estados Unidos não se
percebe que não é político discutir se
uma raça é superior a outra não faz
qualquer tipo de sentido crítico haver
uma discussão como esta mas é o que
acontece é por exemplo o que vimos no
início da planilha ocorre 19 eu tive de
ouvir muitas mensagens no WhatsApp que
me aconselhavam a ir ao supermercado é
sempre ficar todas as compras que eu
pudesse de uma forma muito rápida porque
o Supermercados iriam fechar esse tipo
de mentiras por paga-se este mentiras
Tem consequências mas a parte otimista
da minha conversa convosco hoje é que eu
creio que o êxito de informação depende
sempre de nós porque as mentiras são
criadas
é mas as mentiras podem esbarrar nas
duas qualidades que nós temos de ter
como cidadãos e que são as críticas
convidados que eu queria realçar
curiosidade e ceticismo são duas das
qualidades que mais falta fazem
porventura no mundo em que vivemos hoje
em que toda a gente acha que tem uma
opinião sobre qualquer coisa e já sabe
não precisa de saber mais e por outro
lado a forma como nós somos vítimas
fáceis de uma crença muito superficial
quando navegamos online e é esse o é
esse o problema é essa nossa capacidade
de enfrentar além de termos que ser
curiosos e céticos na forma como lidamos
com o informação as redes sociais
o tempo de perceber também que
informação que consumimos moldar a forma
como vemos o mundo eu não peço que vocês
acreditem no que eu fiz tudo isso eu
peço que façam a experiência se olharem
para o vosso filho e notícias
encarregarem repetir das vezes no mesmo
tema desporto futebol cultura uma coisa
Qualquer que vocês escolheram vão
perceber que aquela ideia ótima Que nós
tínhamos de que as redes sociais nos
abririam os horizontes e os agrião as
perspectivas pode por outro lado da da
mecânica do algoritmo em funcionam as
redes sociais nos algoritmos em
funcionam as redes sociais circunscrever
o nosso mundo muito mais do que o
alargar e Isso muda a forma como vemos o
mundo porque cada vez que nós clicamos e
vemos mais sobre um assunto vamos pensar
sobre esse assunto uma forma muito mais
superficial ao invés do que acreditar
íamos antes de que era com estaremos a
fazer crescer o a universalidade do
nosso pensamento
o esportista somos nós que alimentamos a
fábrica das mentiras somos nós que
podemos emprestando a nossa qualidade de
pessoas confiáveis para os nossos
familiares para os pais para os nossos
irmãos para os nossos tios os nossos
amigos somos nós que ao partilharmos
este tipo de desinformação estamos
alimentar a máquina porque nunca se
esqueçam disto as feito em São criadas
por alguém tem um objetivo particular
seja um negócio como vimos seja o do de
fazer propaganda a uma determinada ideia
política Isso é o que está na cabeça de
quem cria as fake News pois temos formas
das fake News espalhar nas redes sociais
através contas falsas de botes de todas
esses de todos esses mecanismos podem
ser mais ou menos sofisticados de
difusão das fake News mas em última
análise a desinformação só ganha quando
somos nós somos normais e muitas vezes
com boas intenções que as propagamos e
ter difundimos nas nossas redes de
contacto
e nós quando olhamos para o Google e
podemos a fazer qualquer pergunta para
qualquer outro motor de busca temos a
ideia de que estamos perante um dado
completamente novo na nossa história
factores nunca tivemos tanta acesso à
informação a boa informação e documentos
há provas históricas nós podemos fazer
uma navegação numa no motor de busca e
saber muito mais sobre qualquer assunto
mas eu peço suspensa se isto não é um
paradoxo também o nosso tempo porque
todos os dados temos aqui os dados sobre
a literacia notícias em Portugal nos
demonstram que nós estamos cada vez
menos vai informados temos muito mais
informação ao nosso dispor e muito menor
qualidade informação
e o que é que devemos fazer para sermos
Livres dentro e fora das redes sociais
destas que existem e das que ainda nem
sequer foram criadas e criaram para
ficar nós temos de exigir Boa informação
e essa Boa Informação a informação que o
jornalismo deve garantir aos cidadãos e
as cidadãs o jornalismo tem por missão
transformar um assunto qualquer que é
relevante em uma coisa Qualquer que seja
interessante para que as pessoas
conheçam para que as pessoas possam ler
ou ver e essa função do jornalismo mas a
função do jornalismo para qualquer
cidadão e cidadã é que o jornalismo EA
informação informação garantida de boa
qualidade é a única que permite de
formar opiniões ter convicções sobre os
assuntos e por isso eu sei que muitos de
vós agora estarão a pensar que eu estou
a dizer uma coisa que é uma verdade la
palisse mas que informação e não é
sempre boa que a informação também
o jornalismo também erra que o
jornalismo é muitas vezes caro e muitas
vezes desinteressante e eu acho que
vocês têm seguramente razão nessas
críticas todas que pronto e podemos até
ir um pouco mais longe jornalismo vivos
de facto uma ameaça terrível a sua
própria continuidade o jornalismo
baseava-se no financiamento com os seus
leitores me garantiam e na forma como a
publicidade pagar vem com vindos a
publicidade direcionada agora Paga tudo
incluindo os realismos também paga a
propagação da de informação e uma
mentira é sempre muito mais fácil de
difundir Duque um errado chata que
muitas vezes aquilo que o jornalismo é
os não precisa de tempos no mesmo
precisa de espaço o jornalismo não pode
ser viral
Oi e a mãe tem que ser que estejamos a
falar de vitalidade aqui no auditório no
Museu da farmácia porque o conceito de
realidade tornou-se quase positivo para
as redações
Ah e por isso ao fim destes dois anos o
que eu posso testemunhar vos é que
aquela dopamina que nós conseguimos
retirar das redes sociais quando clicam
nas nossas fotos com dizem bem do que
fazemos é muito agradável Mas não é nada
comparável com o critério e com o dever
que nós temos de não sermos cúmplice na
indiferentes perante a forma como a
desinformação vai ganhando espaço no
mundo e vai moldando tudo aquilo que é o
nosso espaço circundante a nossa
sociedade a nossa família a forma como
temos ou não temos Supermercados
esvaziados de produtos e por isso o que
eu gostaria de vos dizer para terminar é
que há sempre uma pergunta que nós temos
de fazer quando estamos perante uma
notícia bombástica nas redes sociais ou
perante um uma coisa Qualquer que nunca
tínhamos visto antes no Google e atenção
Esse é o truque não
e clicar em site não vem sempre não
devemos acreditar em figuras nas redes
sociais que nos dizem coisas e que nós
também não conhecemos a pergunta é se
nós devemos ou não partilhar as
histórias se fizermos essa pergunta se
formos cépticos e Curiosos nós vamos ter
um travão para parar a desinformação
E aí
[Música]